titi le jardin à remonter le temps c'est
le domaine de villarceaux dans le val
d'oise qui va l'accueillir les
paysagistes de ce lieu extraordinaire
unique au monde ont été choisies cette
semaine alors leur tâche créer un
panorama de tous les jardins de tous les
temps et de tous les continents le
domaine de villarceaux se prête à ce
travail délicat reportage xavier grimaud
image signée didier bonnet et la visite
commence en passant de l'ombre à la
lumière
21h15 une heure et demie dans les volets
et les fenêtres
monsieur picot a bien de la chance
il est l'un des rares privilégiés à
pouvoir aujourd'hui profiter de deux
châteaux et d'un parc magnifique
monsieur picot et gardiens au domaine de
villarceaux
jeux de perspective de miroirs l'itrip
d'un rangement végétaux ville a recensé
tout l'art des combinaisons humaines
appliquées aux éléments naturels ce
domaine de 60 hectares recèle des
trésors un château du xviiie siècle un
autre du 16e et une architecture de
jardin exceptionnel des demandes compte
32 sources répertoriées mais ce royaume
de l'eau et des jardins aurait bien
besoin d'un coup de fraîcheur
la restauration de ce patrimoine est
prévue par le conseil régional qui gère
villarceaux depuis deux ans le projet
piloté par l' agence des espaces verts
va même aller beaucoup plus loin
un rêve un peu fou réunir à villarceaux
des jardins du monde entier et de toutes
les époques
une évocation au fil d'une eau qui
remonterait le temps de nos jours
jusqu'au moyen-âge les jardins moghol
arabe anglais ou chinois à 60 km de
paris ont deux types de jardins les
jardins je dirais aux formes raisonnée
maîtrisé par un française à l'italienne
et les jardins plus libres tels que les
jardins japonais chinois ou anglais nous
prendrons grand soin d'eux
faire en sorte que l'on ne se gênent pas
avec l'autre et la place ne manque pas
avec 63 hectares du domaine un jardin
c'est aussi un patrimoine culturel
villarceaux appartient à l'histoire s'y
trouve par exemple les premiers
marronniers planté en france
parc attractif villarceaux ne sera pas
un parc d'attractions ce voudrait-il par
hasard l'anti disneyland le mot trop
fort
ce n'est pas comparable enfin papa d'et
des bijoux en plastique dans un
distributeur sortie d'une boulangerie et
la place vendôme villarceaux espère dans
l'avenir a tiré deux à trois cents mille
visiteurs par an mais il faudra encore
attendre 3 ans minimum avant de
découvrir ce jardin extraordinaire